in this video we're going to think about
the market for apples but the more
important thing isn't the apples it's to
appreciate that the demand curves for a
market are really the sum of the
individual demand curves for every
member of that market and most markets
will have many tens or hundreds of
thousands of actors in it maybe millions
or tens of millions of actors in it but
for the sake of simplifying things we're
going to assume that the apple market
has only two buyers and we have their
demand curves right over here this
demand curve for buyer one and this is
the demand curve for buyer two and so if
the vertical axis is price and maybe
this is price of price per pound of
apples and quantity let's just say
that's pounds per time period maybe
pounds per week we can see that from
buyer one's demand curve that at a price
of one two three four five dollars per
pound they don't want to buy any pounds
at a price of three dollars per pound
they're willing to buy one pound per
week and a price of one dollar per pound
they're willing to buy two pounds per
week we can similarly look at the demand
curve for buyer two and sometimes you'll
see this in table form when it's called
where it's called a demand schedule but
you can see it one two three four five
six seven at seven dollars buyer two is
not interested in apples at seven
dollars a pound at five dollars a pound
they are interested in buying two pounds
of apples per week at three dollars per
pound they're interested in buying so
let's see this is one
two three four
five pounds per week and at one dollar
per pound they're interested in buying
six seven eight pounds per week so based
on this data here buyer one and buyer
two are the only individuals in this
market once again a huge
oversimplification what would the market
demand curve look like pause this video
and try to think that through
well if we go to the various prices so
let's see at a price of
seven dollars there is not going to be
any interest in any apples so
i could maybe put that right over there
at a price of seven dollars but what
happens is the price goes down and we
could just sample what happens when we
get to a price of five dollars buyer one
is still not interested but buyer two is
now willing to buy two pounds per week
and so at a price of five dollars the
market as a whole is willing to buy two
pounds from buyer two and zero pounds
from buyer one so we'll have a total of
two bounds so right over there
so that is at five dollars per pound the
market is willing to is demanding a
quantity of two pounds per week and then
let's go to three dollars at three
dollars now buyer one would buy one
pound per week and buyer two would buy
five pounds per week so in total there
would be six pounds demanded or the
quantity demanded would be six pounds so
three dollars the quantity demanded is
three four five six so that would put us
right about there
and then last but not least once again
i'm just sampling these points to make
the point to you that we really would
just add we would take the sum of these
two curves but we're kind of stacking
them we're stacking them horizontally as
opposed to vertical because for any
given price we're adding up the
quantities so let's go to one dollar a
pound at one dollar a pound buyer one is
willing to buy two pounds and at one
dollar a pound buyer two is willing to
buy eight pounds you put those together
two plus eight you get to ten pounds so
this was two three four five six
seven
eight and then nine and ten we're going
a little bit off the screen here i could
have planned better
better for it but let me go all the way
over here so i'll extend my axis so
that's nine and then this is ten so that
at one dollar
the market would be willing to buy 10
pounds per week
and you could sum at any other point
or any other points in between and what
you would do is
you would get a market demand curve that
looks a little something like this
and you can see
visually what has happened here
for any price value we are summing the
quantities for all of the buyers in the
market now here there's only two buyers
now if you're doing this in the real
world you might be dealing with millions
of buyers but this is just to understand
how a market or where a market demand
curve is actually coming from